the jurgen experience so when did you
start hunting because you're all about
your whole message is like
sustainability right yes and this is the
knock on fishing is that people have an
idea that fishing is not sustainable and
jordan peterson actually talked about
this yesterday and he said what they've
figured out is that if you take
large blocks of the ocean and make them
uh off limits to fishing because all the
fish live within 40 miles of the shore
most of the fish do instead if you take
large blocks of these areas and
designate them as off limits to fishing
then the fish
grow and thrive in those areas and they
venture out into other areas and it's
like it helps it's a win-win well
actually that's
that study was retracted in october
damn it jordan you up
uh sorry jordan um
it's so basically what they call
mpas which is marine protected areas
right and there was the studies who came
to the conclusion of the fact that if
you increase by
something like like four or five percent
the amount of marine protected areas you
would increase the fish stock by 20
and the story was retracted because the
doctor who was in charge of the study
apparently the study the result was
was uh
understudy was depending on the result
of this one and it was a bunch of stuff
that was just like kind of not okay
at all and like the other guy who caught
throws a paper with her was her
brother-in-law so she broke a bunch of
rules when it comes to to etiquette kind
of science wrote the paper was her
brother-in-law yeah there was like some
weird things going on and so the story
the the paper was retracted the paper
being attracted to scientific industry
is pretty pretty intense
here it is retraction of flawed mpa
study implicates larger problems in mpa
science
so they not only didn't only found that
out but they also found out that
basically she had vested interests and
governmental policies
so there was also there was a political
meddling into all of this right so she
had a bias in what she was trying to
achieve from that study so this is this
is also also a pretty good website i'm
i'm partner with them and they're
university of washington and they talk
about a lot of sustainable seafood and
things like that you partner with them
yeah we just built up a blood a blood
basically together to talk about
sustainable seafood you know like people
are interested into seafood which is
about six people in the world but you
know we're a great little community
people are interested to see if a lot of
people are interested in seafood
so what is uh
what's the best way to keep uh ocean
fish and ocean wildlife sustainable
it's it's such a complex topic it's very
very complicated because there's a lot
of
assets to it right but it's the thing
that i tell people is tell me what you
believe in i'll tell you what to eat
because there's not one answer you know
you can think about protecting the ocean
you can think about carbon footprint you
can think about modern slavery you can
think about modern slavery oh there's a
lot of people who works on boats and
different countries that are barely paid
really so if you're buying fish you
might be buying fish that was caught by
slaves yes so there was a big
documentary called
fish
okay so just to clarify on that point
though is the cyst spirits you talk
about that a lot but let's you have a
french accent and sometimes you talk
it's fine english is your second
language i only have one you're better
than me but when you say she's busy
nobody knows the you're talking
about you might see spiricy it's a film
it's a documentary yes c spirits it was
a netflix and they kind of portraits a
pretty doom and gloom situation of
fisheries around the world and it's
this is about 80 percent of the seafood
being consumed around the world that is
still sustainable
there is issues there is issues in third
world countries and remote places the
united states is the best country in the
world when it comes to sustainable
seafood really it's about 99
of
the seafood being consumed that's
coming from the us that is sustainable
oh well that's good yeah so when you say
sustainable how do they do that are they
doing doing that with uh offshore farms
because i know they have some of those
because
i was in uh hawaii um and uh we were
shout out to my friends at strike zone
there was uh we were on a boat and we
were catching these yellowfin tuna and
this guy was telling me um
one of the gentlemen that i was fishing
with that these fish are not even native
to that area
that they were a part of like a like a
farm they have this enormous like kind
of roped-off area where they had left
like i don't know how they do it they
have like a large net or something like
that yeah enormous area and they would
feed these fish and they were using them
for sushi and they were you know
capturing them so they live in the ocean
they would feed them little fish and
like that and plump them up and
then a storm came and up their
net and then they got out into the ocean
and we were catching them and apparently
there was one area where you could catch
a lot of them and that's where we caught
them and i was like this is really
interesting because
could they do this all the time like is
this a way to like re-introduce
fish into the ocean and you know because
they behaved like wild fish it's not
like a any other animal that you raise
in captivity and they become
domesticated fish just have that little
robotic go eat kill
like switch in their brain you don't
have to teach them how to do it
i mean it's
farming is uh it's like it's a pretty
touchy subject because there's good
farming this bat farming you know the
same thing with things with animals
when you think about fish farming the
same thing as cattle this is basically
the exact same thing so this good way to
raise it and it's bad way to raise it
and it's
i think it's just about finding that
species tuna is a bit tough because
they're pelagic so it means that they're
migrate
migratory fish yeah migratory yeah yes
and
so it's you know what they often do
especially with bluefin tuna like tuna
that have very high value
is they're going to catch it in a while
they're going to put in the pans and fat
them up
making sure like they're nice and chubby
and then they can sell it too how do
they catch them in a nap
yeah normally pursain is probably one of
the
it accounts for a lot of uh i think over
65 percent of the tuna cats around the
world it's a great way to catch tuna
because it's basically
you
throw a net around a school of tuna so
there's very little by catch because you
just grab that's cool and then that's it
okay so you don't have to worry about
dolphins yeah so the problem becomes
when you use what you call a fad so fast
is the fishing grading device
and what it does it creates like a
little
habit that normally looks like some
stuff hanging and then you have a small
fish
then the medium fish and the big fish
and the predators around
so what did a lot of people do is they
put those fats in the middle of nowhere
it creates an ecosystem
throwing giant gigantic sorry net around
it pick up everything that's when the
buy cash gets terrible
but
per saying when you're cashing is cool
without fads the buy cash is very very
low so bycatch is what they call it
collateral damage so it's a bunch of
fish that you don't want what do they do
with the fish that they don't want like
what if they do that and they
they throw a net and they get like
like manta rays or something that
they're not looking for it's they throw
them overboard most of the time
they're dead
um
a lot of people try to say like why
don't we just keep the buy cash when it
comes to fish obviously not nobody wants
to eat dolphin apart
and
other parts of the world what parts of
the world eat dolphin japan i think do
they eat dolphin
i know they kill them
that cove documentary is horrible so you
can buy it
at the store
really yes
i want to see dolphin meat on a shelf
let me see that
that's like to me that's like people
meet
it's pretty it's pretty yeah it's pretty
intense they're very very smart
you